our next two presenters are the first
mother-daughter team ever nominated if
you don't count Faye Dunaway in
Chinatown well she's my sister she's my
daughter she's my sister she's my
daughter she rent it so here they are
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Diane Ladd and Laura Dern
hi mommy hi Laura my daughter thanks you
oh oh we have lines how gratifying it is
to contribute to the movies ladies and
gentlemen it's our privilege to share
with you how gratifying it is because
only in the movies is our grasp equal to
our imaginations today
there is nothing that cannot be made
visual the teams of artists and
engineers who create our visual effects
are limited only by budget given enough
time and enough money there is nothing
they cannot bring to the screen the
three films nominated this year are
spectacular fruits of that proud boast
the nominees are back draft nominees
Mikhail sailormen Allen Hall play penny
and Scott Farrar digitally composited a
quarter scale model with live-action
segments filmed on a large rooftop set
but with huge trap doors rigged to
collapse all this had to be timed and
coordinated perfectly to achieve this
spectacular visual effect
in hook a grown-up Peter Pan is able to
fly again thanks to the wizardry of Eric
brave ik Harley Jessup mark Sullivan and
Michael on tre they utilized the
blue-screen process with a mechanical
flying rig and an elaborate combination
of computer graphics and manipulated
matte paintings to create these truly
wondrous splicings Terminator twos
fearsome liquid metal killing machine
was created by using computer-generated
images and digital image processing
live-action production footage was
scanned frame by frame in a computer the
results an amazing example of the
morphing technique by nominees Dennis
Muren Stan Winston gene Warren jr. and
Robert Skotak
and the Oscar goes to
Mariota the Oscar goes to Dennis Muren
Stan Winston gene Warren jr. and Robert
Scott Terminator 2 the judge
thanks to everyone at Industrial Light
and Magic and especially my incredible
computer graphic team - Janet Healy mark
to pay my wife Sarah Gregory and
Gwendolyn and Pez specially Jim Cameron
John Shane Richard Matt Debbie and the
genius Jim Cameron my partner Leslie
Huntley and the great crew at fantasy -
and the vision of Jim Cameron and my
dear partner Elaine Edward my wonderful
brother cinematographer Denis Skotak all
the great team that forward and it's Jim
Cameron who's got to get one of these
soon